cousin
welcome to the cookout the greatest
gathering of black family and food of
all time
if you get an invite to the cookout
whatever you bring has to be fire
because if it's not that chicken ain't
going to be the only thing getting
roasted so i'm going to show you how to
make some staples of the cookout like
uncle rome's barbecue grandma's macaroni
and cheese or unclear sweet potatoes but
today we're starting with an absolute
classic potato salad potato salad seems
simple but it's real easy to mess up now
if you stick with me i'll show you how
to make some potato salad ain't gonna
sit on the table i'm jermaine rawlings
and i'm inviting you to the cookout so
for black people potato salad is a sense
of nostalgia we literally want what our
grandmother made growing up so don't get
cute i use yukon gold potatoes because
they have a very thin skin and i don't
like peeling potatoes because ain't
nobody got time for that you want to
start with cold water and you add the
potatoes too and then bring it to a boil
all right so it's very important to
season your potatoes before the potato
salad is done i use chicken bouillon i
use this with my mashed potatoes i use
this when i'm making pasta because it
gives it a such a more robust flavor and
if you're vegetarian you can use veggie
bouillon and now we're going to stir
this up need a spoon
we're going to bring this up to a boil
let it go for about 15 minutes or until
it's fork tender then i'll strain it and
we'll be right back all right so
potatoes are done i checked them earlier
they were fork tender now it's time to
chop when you're chopping the potatoes
you want to make sure that the pieces
aren't too big or too small people don't
like to eat a full potato with one bite
so chop them up a little bit so that way
they fit on a fork you also don't want
to make them too small because then it
becomes mashed potato salad when you're
mixing it up in a bowl and nobody wants
that the perfect size for the potato
salad is kind of like a pineapple tidbit
just like that as you're cutting you'll
notice some of the peels are coming away
it doesn't really matter it's going to
get mixed up in the bowl anyway so don't
trip that is all our potatoes and now
we're going to move on to
the celery when you're cutting the
celery you want to make sure you get in
very small pieces because once again
nobody likes a chunky potato salad so i
always cut the half and the other half
so that in some places it's called a
quarter i usually go for celery because
i like the texture so it gives you a
little bit of crunch but not too much
crunch and then also like the flavor
just just goes with it and once again
that's what my grandma did celery is
pretty much one of the only vegetables
you want to put in there you don't want
to start putting carrots no raisins no
capers no olives because our
grandparents were not eating those in
their potatoes some people are scared to
use a sharp knife they think it's
dangerous but it's actually dangerous to
use a dull knife so make sure your knife
is sharp and just be careful keep your
eye on what you're doing okay so we're
going to add this to the bowl next we
have hard-boiled eggs boiled eggs is the
only protein you want to add to your
potato salad don't get cute once again
and add smoked salmon as much as i love
bacon a lot of black people don't eat
pork we don't do the whole swine and
dining type thing leave bacon out of it
cause this ain't for you it's for
everybody with the eggs i just give them
a quick chop nothing real precise just
make sure they're they're small enough
to evenly distribute and people like to
have the eggs in there so you want to
make sure they get some so don't put big
old chunks and then you only got three
people with egg eggs in their potato
salad now we're just giving it another
quick chop make sure there's no big
chunks and then we add these to the bowl
all right so onions some people like red
onions some people like brown onions but
for this you want a sweet onion because
it's a milder onion taste depending on
the cookout it might be some people
there that you might want to holla at
you don't want your breath smelling like
onion so you get the sweet onion so that
way it's not as strong and then also
what i do is i grate the onion so that
way you don't have chunks of onion
in the potato salad so before you grate
it you want to cut the onion in half
because i'm only going to use half this
onion by the way take that part off and
then grab it and you're going to grate
it over top
it's almost like you're juicing your
onion we all like onion juice right when
you're grating your onion be careful
because you can lose some skin on them
knuckles if you slip up so i'm crying
little thug tears because this potato
salad will be so good all right we're
done grating onions and as you can see
our balls getting a little full five
pounds of potatoes so uh i'm going to
get a bigger bowl and the ingredients
for our mayo mixture see you guys in a
second all right folks now we're ready
for one of the most important parts the
mayo mixture some people like mayo some
people don't i like mayo in my salad as
well as mustard for this particular
recipe i use half miracle whip and half
mayo some people might be like well
you're just doing too much growing up
and to this day it's kind of like craig
i have like kool-aid no sugar sometimes
peanut butter no jelly ham no burger i
had a little bit of mayo and i had a
little bit of miracle whip when i was
developing the recipe so i just use both
we're gonna add the miracle whip
we're gonna add the mayo
and then we have some dijon mustard and
i like coarse stone ground mustard
because i'm bougie now because you know
i made it you know what i'm saying also
i add hot sauce this right here is
actually frank's because you can get it
everywhere but some people prefer other
hot sauces the hot sauce and the ground
mustard will give it a little bit of
kick it's five pounds of potato so it
won't be too much so don't be scared
worst case scenario you'll need to put
hot sauce in it because you know most
people got it in a bag all right you
always want to make sure you're mixing
this up in a separate bowl because you
don't want to like overwork the potatoes
because then that's how to get mashed
and they get all weird and then it'll
sit on the table and then i'm going to
add in the garlic powder if you grew up
in a black household then you know
everything gets garlic powder onion
powder paprika so mayo mixture is done
now we're going to add everything
together and mix it up all right so now
we're going to add the relish this is
dill relish and then we have the sweet
relish now some might ask why are you
using sweet relish and i told you a
little story about the miracle whip in
the mail same situation also the dill
gives it a little bit of the savory and
then you have the sweet now once you
have everything together you're going to
mix it up again be careful because you
don't want to like mash the potatoes
just give it you know like a little
little mix don't try to get trendy and
like add cheese and all that stuff just
just keep it keep it traditional like
i'm pushing it with the stone ground
mustard to be honest now this this is
looking pretty good i'm just to be
honest with you this ain't going to last
very long that's why i get 5 pounds of
potato all right we got this all mixed
up and we're going to put it in a better
bowl because you don't want to show up
with this bowl if you ever been to the
cookout you know presentation is
everything so you need your garnish so
put a little fresh cracked pepper on
there
you put a little paprika need that
you need the paprika if you think you
put a little bit too much just put a
little bit more with this potato salad
without the paprika on top you need that
a little bit of celery seed and then
some fresh chives don't go getting fancy
adding some tarragon or dill you got
dill from the pickles
and nobody likes licorice so don't put
tarragon in there just a little bit of
chive or
green onion just you know keep it keep
it simple i like my potato salad cold
like every other black person so we're
gonna put this in the refrigerator for a
little bit and then we're gonna have
some people from the cookout try it out
but while we wait i was curious to know
what other ingredients people hate to
see in the potato salad so i sent a team
around tasty to find out let's see what
they came up with what's up tasty
jermaine just led you through everything
that you should do when making the
perfect potato salad but we think it
remains to be said there are some things
that you should absolutely not do as
well so we're gonna go around and taste
the office and see what the good people
have to say name one thing that should
never go in potato salad raisins
no raisins raisins
has anyone said raisins yes raisins i
mean being this black history month the
first thing i got to say is we got to
stop gentrifying recipes as well raisins
leave the raisins out of your potato
salad please for all potlucks
all cookouts all everything no raisins
but make sure the potatoes is firm it
got the skin on them none of that mashed
potato stuff in my potato salad i want
to hear i want that crunch that good
yeah i'm saying yeah all that
no raisins though we're not doing that
raisin stuff yeah so raisins that's a
no-go so pretty much any fruit that
isn't a potato shouldn't be in there
wait wait
you get what i'm saying right no
luckily none of that stuff is in here
but don't take my word for it let's let
the homies try it out
the ratio of mayonnaise so everything
else is great approved
[Music]
not a single raisin approved
this does not bring this onto our
ancestors approved well there you have
it that's how you make potato salad
worthy of the cookout so tell me in the
comments what this you want to bring to
the cookout and maybe i'll tell you how
to make it i'm about to go take a walk
around the corner with my cousins but
always remember no raisins i'm jamae
rawlings peace
oh yes
[Music]
you